Speaker 1: Tonight, Joe Biden will be delivering
his first joint address, his first address
to a joint session of the House and Senate.
But it's not called the State of the Union
address.
Often in a president's first year, the State
of the Union is just not called the State
of the Union.
And sometimes it's not in February or January.
It's coming in April.
And we will be live tonight on YouTube, Twitter
and Facebook with Joe Biden's first address
to a joint session of the House and Senate.
We now have learned that tonight Joe Biden
will propose a one point eight trillion dollar
plan, which will include national paid family
leave, universal pre-K, free community college,
subsidized child care and a whole bunch of
other things.
Now, will it pass as proposed tonight?
Of course not.
It never does.
That's the same with every president.
This is the starting point.
But Joe Biden will be introducing his American
families plan tonight.
It is part two of the so-called build back
better economic agenda.
There's the two trillion roughly infrastructure
and jobs plan that was released earlier this
month.
This is now going to be the next piece of
it, a one point eight dollars billion package.
It is being called a generational investment
in the future.
It is billed as something that will help us
compete with China.
It will transform the US economy, and it includes
one trillion dollars in spending over the
next 10 years and an additional eight hundred
billion, which would be targeted tax credits
for middle class families.
The proposal also includes cracking down on
tax loopholes used by high income tax filers.
Joe Biden wants to nearly double the capital
gains rate from 20 to nearly 40 percent for
households making over a million dollars a
year.
I don't think that's going to happen, but
it's nice that he's proposing it.
Two hundred and twenty five billion dollars
for national paid leave, another two.
Twenty five billion for child care.
And of course, Republicans have already been
criticizing it.
They will be against it in their rebuttal
tonight to Joe Biden's speech.
They will come out against it.
What's my thought about this?
I think that it is a very reasonable initial
framework.
We've talked before about, oh, but how will
we pay for it?
First of all, that's never asked about how
do we buy missiles.
It's never asked about how we pay for war.
It's never asked about how we pay for tax
cuts for the rich.
It's asked by Republicans when it's actual
programs that they believe are either wasteful
or that go to people who are undeserving in
some way under this umbrella of the morality
that they apply to.
Who deserves something from the government.
Of course, they're going to be against it.
Our new framework for understanding debt and
deficit.
Is that not every dollar of debt is created
equal if we take on a dollar of debt to give
a really rich person a tax break, statistically
most of that money they save just sits in
a bank account with a relatively low economic
multiplier.
If we accrue a dollar of debt in order to
give somebody a better education, which allows
them to earn more later in life, paying more
taxes into the government, or if we take on
a dollar of debt to give someone health care
that doesn't otherwise have it, so that now
they can get a preemptive treatment, preventive
treatment, rather than going to the doctor
when they are already sick.
And then they miss fewer days of work and
earn higher wages.
You understand how there are stimulative reasons
for the government to deficit spend and less
or non stimulative reasons?
The framework here is that most of this stuff
would have a higher economic multiplier than
just tax cuts for the rich.
Now, do I think that this is going to pass
as proposed?
There's no way in hell, there's no way in
hell, because even Democrats are not unanimously
on board here with the things that Joe Biden
is going to be proposing.
So I think that Joe Biden is very well positioned
right now with the success of vaccination,
the passage of the one point nine dollars
billion covid stimulus.
Joe Biden has a lot of political capital right
now.
We've been wondering how is he going to choose
to spend it?
And it is going to be on this two trillion
plus now, one point eight dollars billion
package.
Now, the the I am not looking for I think
I'm committing.
We'll see.
I think I'm committing not to deal with the
really predictable right wing opposition,
which is where are we going to get this four
trillion dollars?
It's just like I'm tired of it.
I'm tired of it.
I've done deep dives on exactly where we can
cut spending.
I've explained modern monetary theory and
the reality about how a country's debt is
not the same as a household that we've done
it all.
So if they're going to just come out and say
we just we don't have the four trillion and
we can't keep printing money, I'm so tired
of that.
Maybe I'll address it in passing, but I'm
not going to address that in detail.
I'm more interested.
And hearing from Republicans good faith critiques
of why the spending specifically is not a
good investment in the future of America,
like actually tell me, OK, he wants to do
free tuition on community college.
Why is that bad?
It seems to me that it is, number one, a great
alternative for four year to four year schools
for people for whom maybe that's not the best
fit.
It is a great feeder to reduce the total costs
for people who ultimately do want to go to
a four year school and earn a bachelor's degree,
it seems economically stimulative.
It will make us more competitive.
Tell me why it's a bad idea to spend money
on that rather than just throwing at me?
Well, for four trillion, whereas Biden getting
it.
Come on, that's pathetic.
That's flaccid.
It's a very flimsy criticism.
So I'm hoping to engage more substantively
with criticisms that are made in good faith
and that are not just the same old thing we've
heard time and time again.
That's tonight.
Joe Biden will announce it.
I will be live starting at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And I hope you'll join me for
that speech tonight.